African heads of state our meeting in
Nairobi for the inaugural Africa climate
Summit they're deliberating in the
Kenyan capital on how the continent can
take climate action among the aims are a
common plan for tackling climate change
proposals for a new international
financing framework and plans for
dealing with biodiversity loss let's get
the latest it is because we all have a
shared stake in the Arts ability to
sustain life
that we must Envision together a future
that Embraces the values of equality
human security and shared prosperity
Africa
possesses all the necessary conditions
to realize
this future
Australian Catherine sonar who's in the
Kenyan capital and Catherine much to
discuss and I presume Great Expectations
yes the agenda here is very rich the
delegates are talking about different
issues that affect uh the continent
continent including uh climate migration
uh including uh climate uh Finance
conservation we know that communities
are saying that they want to be vote to
be involved in a conservation as well
and now joining me to talk about all
this is
um ademola ajabe who has focused or
focuses on conservation what are your
expectations when it comes to this side
thank you so very much for having me
this Africa climate Summit the first
ever is really timely in the sense that
it's bringing to the full conversation
around climate Finance as we all know
Africa is suffering the brunt of climate
change impact but there's also a huge
opportunity that can be unlocked through
a garden like this in terms of how do we
recalibrate or reimagine our options for
financing uh climate change mitigation
and adaptation on the continent so in
terms of expectation is to see tangible
outcome coming in that direction in
terms of what are the manual sustainable
Finance mechanisms that Africa can tap
into to cope with the impact of climate
change what what uh pressure should be
used should be used when it comes to
International
seeing a climate change
very good question in terms of the
pressure that we need to use I think the
narrative is in very rapidly in the
sense that Africa used to play victim to
the influx of climate change but more
and more we're beginning to see that
there are actually benefits that we need
to catalyze on Leverage as Africa a very
good example is the wealth on the
continent Africa is home to a fourth
it's one of the most holds one of the
most important carbon sink in the world
the Congo Basin so how do we cut that
from a financial perspective looking at
the financial architecture for
nature-based solution that is very
critical so coming to how we work with
the West is really about really a
negotiation that monetize the impact and
the benefit of this nature-based
solution like climate mitigation in
Africa to support climate uh impact
financing across the continent what
needs to be done to involve more
communities local communities who are
the most affected by climate absolutely
communities face the brunt of climate
change and have traveled around the
continent seeing how Community you know
suffer this uh climate impact however
they have a big role to play in the
sense that they actually the concerns of
nature
in protecting this natural assets and
they've done that for Generations so one
of the things we need to look at is
technology transfer because local action
is critical but how do we use local
action to solve Global problem through
scaling that's the first one the second
is about financing and Finance in that
skill talk about climate change Finance
is really abundant in the west but when
it comes to capacity to access the
financing in Africa is almost
non-existent and that's one of the
reasons why at The Nature Conservancy we
created a carbon accelerator program to
support one providing the technical
assistance to communities and local
based organization and two to provide
food financing support you know access
carbon credit which is working but the
question is how do we scale because it's
not only for us to have solutions that
are working at local level but we need
these solutions to be skilled to benefit
more people across the continent and at
the end of it all after this Summit what
should be Africa's position especially
when it comes to cop 28 at the end of
the year we're expecting that the Africa
climate Summit in the next couple of
days 28 presidents from across Africa 40
African ministers and I'm told that more
than 30 000 delegates have registered so
we expect to see very ambitious
commitment coming out through with
support from the African group of
negotiators under the United Nations
framework convention on climate change
and all that no outcome feeding into
what is called Nairobi declaration I
expect to see the Nairobi declaration
informing the climate agenda later this
year at the UAE and topmost on that list
is how do we diversify the funding
stream the finest mechanism for climate
mitigation and adaptation in Africa
thank you very much for your time
um so the delegates here will be talking
about many things and they uh at the end
of it all they hope that the outcome
will be good and the heads of state will
be able to present uh that agenda to cop
28 in the coming weeks Catherine for us
there in Nairobi thank you